la cinquième étape de paris nice
interrompu par des manifestants après
avoir fait le coup de poing bernard
hinault parlait d' abandonner mais tout
va bien ce soir il est troisième au
classement général
mesdames messieurs bonsoir une étape
bousculade dans la course paris nice on
attendait du sport et c'est un pugilat
auquel on a assisté
quand les ouvriers des chantiers navals
de la ciotat ont interrompu cette
cinquième étape une étape qui conduisait
les coureurs de miramas à la seyne sur
mer la course a dû être neutralisée
pendant une dizaine de kilomètres après
un échange de coups de poing entre
bernard hinault et les manifestants
hinault entendait poursuivre sa route ce
que ces mêmes manifestants n'ont pas
apprécié lionel chamoulaud sur son vélo
bernard hinault se fâche dans la
descente du col de l'espigoulier hinault
fait exploser le peloton
une vingtaine de coureurs sont dans son
sillage mais robert millar le leader est
lâché bonne opération pour le breton
mais mauvaise surprise après 154 km de
cours un barrage de manifestants
voilà qui opère
autant que de passer il se retrouve à
terre et se fâche de nouveau
comme les agriculteurs à orcières
merlette les sidérurgistes à fontaine au
pire à l'occasion du tour de france
cette fois ce sont les ouvriers des
chantiers navals de la ciotat les
mineurs de gardanne qui bloque les
coureurs du paris nice
finalement le calme revient hinault au
ski il a un instant envisagé l'abandon
les organisateurs dont donc un nouveau
départ à 25 km de l'arrivée en tenant
compte des écarts acquis le groupe une
en conserve son avance et à l'arrivée à
scène eddy planckaert l'emportent devant
kelly et hymne au classement général 1er
kelly avec 32 secondes avant sur roche
et le 41e sur in au troisième